I am
and there really is the funny one you
know it what episode is it it's one of
those episodes where they keep using
clips from earlier episodes as
flashbacks because the writers weren't
grave enough to come up with an episode
that week why are you watching I just
have a feeling Branson I asked me a
question at the live event that's gonna
somehow get me talking about friends I
just figured why not turn it on oh you
won't watch something else
[Music]
how about we make something else huh I
said how about we make something else
what brought this on
you said do you want to watch something
else oh I'm sorry I'm sorry so much the
time you listen I was thinking we're
gonna be at a live event right we're
gonna be at a movie theater why don't we
come up with a sketch it premiered at
the theater come up with something that
you know unlike anything we've ever done
before I mean I feel like they're all
pretty different from each other that's
not so self-aware something I thought so
you know referential something that is
not so expositional with its dialogue
something creative I like this episode
of Friends you're sitting up this sketch
aren't you you're damn right upset I
have a sketch let's do it let's do it
[Music]
hmm DejaVu all right man I'm gonna start
writing the sketch do not bother me
while I'm in the zone
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
something you know something yeah the
hell are you do
coming over this case what are you doing
6:00 in the morning 6:00 in the morning
6:00 in the morning signal one six six
two six two six and six a.m. until me up
at 6:00 a.m. dude it's 6:00 in the forum
what the [ __ ] are you doing dude
you need to get some sleep you're really
stressing yourself out over this sketch
I'm fine John aren't you the backing
around here your beauty rest
[Music]
what are you peeing in jars for
[Music]
I'm in the zone man I have locked myself
in this room and I will not be leaving
this room and so there's a new sketch on
that [ __ ] computer for arena [ __ ]
sin Oh Ange there's a bathroom right
here it's in a different room there's no
door your piss smell woke me up fine
I'll throw it outside
wake up Johnny
okay
what are you doing are you crazy I'm
crazy crazy enough to get the both of us
okay take it easy okay do you want to
help me come up with a sketch
Greg I love you I love you please be
careful and still I couldn't hurt him
even though I've been up for three days
peeing in jars and pooping in between
the cushions of the couch John was
sitting on earlier in this sketch I
couldn't that no matter how irritated I
was by usually writing the sketches I
still wanted a good hell as reference
[ __ ] wack down the [ __ ] kill you
how's it feel [ __ ] feel why you smell
like [ __ ] in here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you want to give the people something
new you have to give them the truth
what's the truth John
[Music]
[Applause]
we gotta go full game
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]